you
I wrote a book called how many people
can the earth support and I've made a
real effort to find every scientifically
allegedly scientifically-based estimate
of how many people the earth can support
and I found 66 after I published the
book naturally I found a few more but
they didn't change the conclusions in
the last half century the estimates
ranged of how many people the earth can
support ranged from less than 1 billion
to more than a trillion which is a
thousand billions they can't all be
right what's going on they make
different assumptions they make
different assumptions about the average
level of well-being that people will
want to have and the distribution of
well-being and about how we will settle
our differences whether we'll settle
them by peaceful negotiation or by
violent methods and what kinds of
economies will we have will we trade or
will we not trade and what kinds of
families we really have who will take
care of young people and who will take
care of old people and what kind of an
environment do we want they make
assumptions about whether we want
parking lots or parks Jaguars with a
small J or Jaguars with a big J what you
know do we what do we want tin cans with
wheels are we going to walk are we going
to take a bike so they make very
different assumptions and I don't think
this is a question that's completely
specified it's not a science question
and the numbers that are given our too
often political numbers the numbers
intended to persuade you that we have
too many people or we could have a lot
more people and we don't have enough
people I really don't having spent four
years writing that book I now think that
we should pay much more attention to the
quality of life of the people who we
have now and the quality of life for the
children that we're going to have in the
next year and
five years and 20 years and so I've
shifted my emphasis from trying to
answer a question that's not well
formulated in the first place to what
can we do to improve life for ourselves
and for the children and especially for
the billion people who are chronically
hungry now it's it's it's amazing to me
so you ask about how many people can the
earth support last year we grew enough
grain to feed decently between nine and
eleven billion people okay we have under
seven billion and of those 1 billion are
chronically hungry they're not getting
enough how is it possible we're growing
9 to 11 we've got a billion hungry
people we're only seven billion
altogether how does that work for every
three kilograms of grain that goes into
a human mouth we put two kilograms of
grain into an animal mouth and we have
put animals in the queue for food ahead
of a billion people and the reason is
the billion people are poor they got no
money and they're economically invisible
because the price of food doesn't take
account of hunger especially children
they've got no they don't have it and so
they are hungry we've got a billion
hungry people and we're feeding forty
percent of the consumed grain to animals
not to mention the 16 that goes into the
machines so I think we've got a problem
when we put machines and animals ahead
of people
well I don't know that it's it's wasted
I mean when people the people who are
getting rich are demanding the meat they
want in the economic sense they buying
meat they want it and the farmers are
supplying where there's demand what I
think we need to do is take several
steps to break the cycle of poverty so
that the people who are poor can also
get grain or meat or whatever they want
I mean if they're vegetarian fine let
them eat vegetables if they want meat
let them buy meat but part of the
problem is that meet consumers in rich
countries have no idea of the
environmental impacts of eating meat so
the price of meat does not reflect the
real costs in terms of wellbeing for the
earth it does not reflect the land
degradation due to overgrazing it does
not reflect the water pollution it does
not reflect the greenhouse gas emission
that affects everybody whether you eat
meat or not so the prices do not
incorporate the real costs it doesn't
the price of meat doesn't incorporate
the health risks the infectious diseases
the e.coli infection is the salmonella
you know there was just another food
recall in the New York Times yesterday
because of Salmonella it doesn't reflect
the losses of species so the first thing
I would do is get the prices of meat to
reflect all of the costs and I think
that would be a signal of what's in to
the consumer and the other thing is to
provide the consumers in the West with
information what are the consequences of
eating eight but that's not enough
because there's a whole billion people
who are outside of the price system and
for them I think we need three kinds of
interventions you asked what to do here
are three things I think we should do
there are about 200 million women in the
world who have an unmet need for
contraception
that means if you ask them do you want
to have another child and they say no
and are you having intercourse and
exposed to the risk of conception and
they say yes they have an unmet need for
contraception there are about 200
million it would cost about four billion
dollars to fix that problem that is not
a big deal we could fix that the second
thing and we should be educating teenage
boys and girls about contraception
before they become parents secondly we
should have nutrition education for
pregnant women for parents and for
teenagers how to make a whole protein
out of whatever your local food is rice
and beans it's a great combination it
gives you a complete protein but in
Liberia a lot of people eat just the
polished white rice because that's the
upper-class food and beans is cheap food
and they consider that not dignity this
is where culture comes in eating poor
people's food is not dignified as a
result they get malnutrition but if we
could teach people to make whole protein
from whatever is locally available by
nutrition education that would be a big
step and the third thing is as a
temporary measure we need to provide
good diets to pregnant women lactating
women and their offspring and infants up
to the age of three because that's when
their brains are being laid down and
give them a start to get out of this
trap of poverty the poverty makes them
have bad diets and the bad diets stunts
their mental and physical growth and
that keeps them in poverty so there are
some specific things that we can do to
get out of this despite
you